the president of Kyrgyzstan made some
very controversial comments at a press
conference saying that women who wear
miniskirts do not become suicide bombers
this is president Alba's beck at at
mumbai 'iv who said that women are more
vulnerable to Islamic radicalization if
they put on Islamic dress he also
attacked those in his country where
eighty percent of the population is
Muslim who were critical of women who
wear more revealing outfits and the
reason for all of this commentary to
even happen is that over the last
several weeks there's been this
government-sponsored campaign to put up
banners dissuading women in the country
from wearing Islamic clothing
particularly the hijab niqab and burqa
and in advance of a visit from the
German Chancellor Angela Merkel this was
sort of a scaled-up and some of the
banners were criticized for the design
of the banners which showed both women
in Islamic dress and women more casually
dressed and there was big criticism and
responding to that president Atambayev
said when we erected banners some smart
people appeared and started pointing at
miniskirts
our women have been wearing miniskirts
since the 1950s and they never thought
about wearing an explosive belt
he then portrayed the wearing of some
Islamic clothing as not only being out
of step with the contemporary culture of
the country but also is potentially
dangerous he actually said the following
and I'll put it up on the screen for you
terrorists are insane people clothes
also can change one's thoughts sometimes
when we were searching for prisoners who
had escaped a detention centre MELAS
torgan by of the former interior
minister came to me and said that they
had been eavesdropping on telephone
conversations of wives and mistresses of
criminals their wives and mistresses
wore sacks on their heads and they
wanted to organize bombings some people
said these are sexist comments some
people were angry and this does bring up
a big correlation versus causation issue
right miniskirts and radicalization are
they connected do we see correlation is
there causation back in 2014 the
president also spoke about this and he
was a little bit less hyperbolic and
mavin
be closer to what he really means saying
that it's not conservative clothing or
Muslim traditions that he has a problem
with but what he described as the
Arabization of society and the
deprivation of the Kirby's nation of its
language and traditions
I want a stake take it a step further if
I may Lewis because this could have
turned into a sort of sexist and
one-sided discussion men and miniskirts
also don't don't become suicide bombers
and I'm sort of being facetious but my
point is it's not because of miniskirts
that you see suicide bombing or because
of a lack of miniskirts or whatever the
case may be I think it's more that if
miniskirts are an acceptable part of
society for men or women I don't think
it is actually related to gender you're
less likely to be in a position to be
radicalized in the way that we've been
seeing
yeah his his choice of words is strange
but it's about combating radicalization
and this an extreme form of the Muslim
religion and I get it and it's important
for a government and a president to be
proactive about these things assuming
they are not of the same mindset is the
thing they're trying to fight against
for example Turkey and so poor choice of
words but the message I understand and
it's it's it's good that he's making
people think twice about slamming casual
dress yeah
slamming miniskirts it's also a
practical matter Jason because if you
are wearing a miniskirt it becomes way
high way more difficult to hide a bomb
or a suicide vest there is a sort of
pragmatic aspect to this yeah very much
so and you know to take that a step
further for the sexism part of it you
know as a man I could wear a codpiece
with the WMD to cover my scrotum okay
well things have taken an interesting
turn here I'll mention one other thing
which is would this campaign actually
just divide people more right I mean
even even if this is correct like oh
yeah when you see miniskirts you see
less radicalization whatever you do also
have to consider is this
a campaign which by in flaming people
will help or will it actually just
divide people further and that's my
biggest concern with the campaign I'm
not in any way offended by it yeah he's
only in flaming one side and that
happens to be we have presented the
Huntress side that will that will bomb
you but still it needs to be said it
needs to be done especially if there is
a trend in the country where where they
are regressing and you got to do
something about it big picture when we
talk about how to prevent radicalization
in the first place
I don't think miniskirts is the answer
per se but a liberalisation when it
comes to social values is a push back
against radicalization so in that sense
I think we have to think about what
types of values and ideas should be
promoted in order to push back against
radicalization